SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD EGGMAN.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN NGUYEN.
NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA PORTANTINO.
ROTH. RUBIO. SATO SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. STERN. UMBERG
WAHAB. WIENER. WILK MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WHAT? OUR
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS. BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE RISE. WE'LL BE LED IN
PRAYER TODAY. THIS MORNING BY
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING AS WE'LL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
SISTER GORMAN. SO LET US CENTER
OURSELVES IN GOD'S PRESENCE. AND
THE FOLLOWING QUOTE IS
ATTRIBUTED TO ELDERS OF THE HOPI
NATION. WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS THE 11TH
HOUR. NOW WE MUST GO BACK AND
TELL THE PEOPLE THAT THIS IS THE
HOUR, AND THERE ARE THINGS TO BE
CONSIDERED AND NØ YOUR GARDEN,
SPEAK YOUR TRUTH, CREATE YOUR
COMMUNITY, BE GOOD TO EACH OTHER
, AND DO NOT LOOK OUTSIDE
YOURSELF FOR YOUR LEADER. THE
TIME OF THE LONE WOLF IS OVER.
BANISH THE WORD STRUGGLE FROM
YOUR ATTITUDE AND YOUR
VOCABULARY. ALL WE DO NOW MUST
BE DONE IN A SACRED MANNER AND
IN CELEBRATION. WE ARE THE ONES
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR. SO
GRACIOUS GOD OF ALL TIME AND OF
THIS MOMENT. WE THANK YOU FOR
WHERE YOU WOULD LEAD US THIS DAY
IN SERVICE OF YOUR PEOPLE WITH
COMPASSION, COURAGE AND
COMMITMENT. AND IN ALL OF YOUR
MAKING US WORTHY TO BE THE
PEOPLE WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR.
AMEN. MEMBERS, JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
DALLI, HE'S PREPARED. SENATOR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS. I
WOULD LIKE TO, WELCOME THE BIG
VALLEY JUNIOR, SENIOR, EIGHTH
GRADE CLASS FROM BEAVER. HERE TO
THE CAPITAL. UP HERE IN THE
GALLERY. I'D LIKE TO JUST NOTE
THAT EVERY YEAR I SEND OUT A BOX
OF SEE'S CANDY TO EVERY SINGLE
OFFICE IN THE ASSEMBLY. IN THE
SENATE. MEGAN AND I DO THAT. AND
IT'S A FUNDRAISER FOR THE EIGHTH
GRADE CLASS TO COME DOWN TO THE
CAPITOL FROM OUR LITTLE
COMMUNITY OF BEAVER. SO THEY'RE
HERE TODAY. THEY'RE IN THE
GALLERY. I'D ASK THE SENATE TO
GIVE THEM A WARM WELCOME.
WELCOME ON Tê. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NOW
MOVING ON, MEMBERS, MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNORS WILL BE
DEEMED RED. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ, AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED, MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, RULED JOINT RULE 62 A
WILL BE SUSPENDED FOR BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEES ONE, THREE AND
FOUR TO MEET TODAY WITHOUT FOUR
DAYS NOTICE IN THE DAILY FILE.
NOW MOVING ON TO DOUBLE ACTIONS.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
MEASURES REPORTED FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
THE RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS WILL
BE GIVEN THEIR SECOND READING
UPON BEING REPORTED IN ORDER TO
THIRD READING WITHOUT OBJECTION,
MEASURES REPORTED WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED, WILL BE GIVEN THEIR
SECOND READING AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED AND RETURNED TO SECOND
READING. UPON BEING REPORTED.
NOW RECOGNIZING SENATOR ASHBY.
THANK YOU, PRESIDING OFFICER. I
WOULD LIKE TO, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN NGUYEN MOVE.
SORRY, REQUEST TO REMOVE FILE
ITEM Ã 30, WHICH IS AB 1246 FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEPHANIE
NGUYEN. THE JUST WILL NOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE
UNDER SECOND READING. WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL 1418. SENATE
BILL 1051. THANK YOU. NOW WE'RE
MOVING TO GOVERNANCE OF
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE
THREE. SENATOR LAIRD, HE'S
PREPARED. WHEN YOU'RE READY, YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT, FINAL ITEM NUMBER
THREE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ANAHIT. MARCELLA SANDOVAL ARAIZA
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. SHE CURRENTLY IS
COMPLETING HER BACHELOR'S DEGREE
IN GLOBAL STUDIES AT UC
BERKELEY, IS ONE OF THE TWO
STUDENT REPRESENTATIVES TO THE
COMMISSION. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
17TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ON ITS
APPOINTMENT? HEARING NONE.
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ROLE ONE TIME. WE HAVE A MEMBER
UP THE FLOOR. SO WE'RE GOING TO
ASK THAT WE GO THROUGH THE ROW
ONE TIME AND THEN PUT IT ON CALL
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE, I'LL RODA-GIL
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NÓ.
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. I NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN.
NØ. NILO NO. OKOBO. NO. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO. SKINNER
AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
WILK. AYE THE SENATOR MOVES TO
CALL. NOW. WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM FOUR. SENATOR LEHRER. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF TY MILDER FOR APPOINTMENT AS
DIRECTOR OF THE DIVISION OF
PETROLEUM MARKET OVERSIGHT AT
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. PRIOR TO THIS ROLE,
HE WAS SERVING AS COUNSEL TO THE
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
THE ANTITRUST DIVISION AT THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL 24TH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
SKINNER? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS APPOINTMENT. MR.
MILDER PRESENTED AT A OVERSIGHT
HEARING, RECENT. AND HE WAS VERY
PROFESSIONAL, THOROUGH, AND I
THINK HE IS A EXCELLENT PERSON
FOR THIS POSITION AND I
ENCOURAGE AND I VOTE AYE. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SENATOR LEHRER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO Ó SENATORS? SENATOR GROVE
THANK YOU. MR. PRESIDENT. I
STAND IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
APPOINTMENT. IT WAS CREATED THIS
APPOINTMENT WAS CREATED BY SB
ONE TWO. THIS APPOINTMENT IS
SOMEONE WHO IS GOING AFTER THE
PETROLEUM MARKET OVERSIGHT OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT WHAT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE PENALTIES
THAT ARE BEING APPLIED HERE AND
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS GOING TO
DO NOTHING BUT INCREASE THE COST
OF FUEL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, FOR ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS. CGRTS THERE IS NO
VIABLE SOLUTION, A LOT OF PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY THIS, ESPECIALLY
PRODUCERS, ARE PRICE TAKERS, NOT
PRICE SETTERS. SO THEY TAKE A
GLOBAL MARKET PRICE, THEY HAVE
NO CONTROL OVER THE PRICE THAT'S
PUT FORWARD. AND THE ISSUE THAT
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING, INCLUDING
MR. MIDLER, WHO, AGREES TO THIS
AS THE ISSUE IS A SUPPLY ISSUE.
BUT WE HAVE ELIMINATED OUR
REFINING CAPACITY, AND WE HAVE A
VERY MINIMAL SUPPLY. AND TO
CONTINUE GOING DOWN A PATH THAT
IS GOING TO JUST CREATE HIGHER
FUEL PRICES FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS COMPLETELY ABSURD.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT MR. MIDLER
IS THE PERSON FOR THIS JOB, AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
NO VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, HEARING AND SEEING
NONE. SENATOR LEHRER, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD, BUT
THAT WAS THE DEBATE WE HAD WHEN
WE ADOPTED THIS BILL. IT PASSED
BOTH HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE,
AND THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT.
THOSE ARE SETTLED ISSUES WITH
REGARD TO THE STATE. AND NOW WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY THAT'S
VERY QUALIFIED TO IMPLEMENT THAT
BILL IN OUR COMMITTEE HEARING,
MR. MILDER DEMONSTRATED THAT
CONSIDERABLY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FOUR. ELLEN AYE. ALVARADO
GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI. NO
DODD. BARRASSO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENJIVAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. OCHOA.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO
NO. SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE THE
SENATOR MOVES TO CALL NOW. WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SIX. SENATOR
LAIRD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF DAVID
GARCIA AND JONATHAN GLAZER FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE CIVIL RIGHTS
COUNCIL. MR. GARCIA IS A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE INNER
CITY LAW CENTER AND AN ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR AT CSU LOS ANGELES. HE
ALSO SERVES NOW AS THE COUNCIL'S
CHAIR. MR. GLAZER IS A PROFESSOR
AT UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF LAW.
PREVIOUSLY TAUGHT AT UCLA SCHOOL
OF LAW, UC IRVINE SCHOOL OF LAW,
AND STANFORD LAW SCHOOL. BOTH
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY EIGHTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION, SENATOR? MEN? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I ONCE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING WITH
PROFESSOR GLAZER ON THE FACULTY
OF UC IRVINE, SAT IN ON MANY
FOCUS GROUPS, STUDY GROUPS WITH
HIM, AND I CAN ATTEST TO HIS
THOUGHTFULNESS AND
PROFESSIONALISM. I WOULD URGE
YOU ALL TO SUPPORT HIS
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL MICROPHONES,
SENATOR LEHRER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM SIX. ALAN
AYE. ALL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPERM AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ
AYE. DALLI DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN
NILO. OCHOA NO. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE RUBIO.
AYE. SATO NO. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE.
UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE.
WILK. AYE THE SENATOR MOVES THE
CALL NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING
TO SENATE. THIRD READING. WE
HAVE FOUR ITEMS. FIRST UP IS
FILE ITEM 16. SENATOR STERN.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
BILL 1136 BY SENATOR STERN. AN
ACT RELATING TO GREENHOUSE GASES
. SENATOR STERN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TO PRESENT THIS OVERSIGHT
MEASURE AS THE CHAIR OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES. BACK
DURING THE PASSAGE OF THE LAST
CAP AND TRADE EXTENSION, THE
LEGISLATURE AGREED THAT WE WOULD
MAINTAIN ONGOING OVERSIGHT AND
NOT JUST WRITE A BLANK CHECK TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AS THEY
ADMINISTER OUR CLIMATE PROGRAMS.
THIS BILL WOULD STRENGTHEN THOSE
OVERSIGHT ABILITIES AND HONE OUR
FOCUS ON THE SCOPING PLAN THAT
WE KNOW IS A CRITICAL GUIDING
DOCUMENT, BUT ALSO A PLACE WHERE
WE NEED TO DRILL DOWN. SO HOPING
FOR YOUR AYE. VOTE HERE AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 16. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI DODD. AYE. DORADO. AYE.
EGGMAN. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE HURTADO. JONES LAIRD.
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE.
OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROD. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE MOVE THE CALL, SENATOR.
MOVES THE CALL NOW. MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 57.
SENATOR RUBIO, SHE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ SENATE
RESOLUTION 72 BY SENATOR RUBIO,
RELATIVE TO THE RELATIVE TO
MATERNAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH, SENATOR RUBIO,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE,
TODAY, I PROUDLY RISE TO PRESENT
SR 72, A WOMEN'S CAUCUS
RESOLUTION, WHICH PROCLAIMS MAY
2024 AS MATERNAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH. DURING
THIS MONTH, WE RECOGNIZE AND
BRING ATTENTION TO THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF MATERNAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR WOMEN AND
ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO GIVE BIRTH
ACROSS OUR STATE. MENTAL HEALTH
IS A CRITICAL ASPECT OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE, AND WE
CANNOT IGNORE THE GLARING AND
RACIAL AND ETHNIC DISPARITIES
THAT CONTINUES TO PERSIST IN OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY. THIS LACK
OF ACCESS CAN HAVE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES ON MATERNAL AND
INFANT HEALTH OUTCOMES. ONE AREA
THAT DEMANDS OUR FOCUS IS
ENSURING EQUAL ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
OPTIONS, INCLUDING INFERTILITY
AND FERTILITY TREATMENTS. WE
MUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE PROFOUND
IMPACT OF MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS DURING PREGNANCY OR
UP TO ONE YEAR FOLLOWING
PREGNANCY. THAT INCLUDES
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY DISORDER,
OBSESSIVE COMPULSIVE DISORDER,
PTSD, BIPOLAR ILLNESS, AND, MUCH
MORE ALARMINGLY, 1 IN 5 MOTHERS
IS AFFECTED BY MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS, AFFECTING
800,000 FAMILIES EACH YEAR IN
THE US. SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
STIGMA. AMONG OTHER FACTORS, MAY
ALSO PREVENT INDIVIDUALS FROM
SEEKING THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME. LET
US JOIN TOGETHER IN SUPPORTING
THE WELL-BEING OF WOMEN AND ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO GIVE BIRTH
ACROSS OUR STATE. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE?
SENATOR THANK YOU. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SR 72 MATERNAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH.
THE SOCIAL ISOLATION OF THE
PANDEMIC HIGHLIGHTED THE
PREVALENCE OF POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION, BUT IT ALSO TIPPED
THE SCALES FOR MANY WOMEN WHO
HAD UNDIAGNOSED MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS. WE ARE SEEING AN
INCREASE IN DIAGNOSES OF ADHD
AND OTHER DISORDERS IN ADULT
WOMEN IN MOTHERS, BECAUSE ALL
THEIR COPING MECHANISMS FELL
APART WITH A COMBINATION OF THE
PANDEMIC AND MOTHERHOOD. AS
CLICHE AS IT SOUNDS, IT DOES
TAKE A VILLAGE TO RAISE A CHILD,
AND WE'VE ERODED THE VILLAGE
THROUGH POOR POLICY MAKING BY
FAILING TO PROTECT PEOPLE FROM
BEING DISPLACED FROM THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY HAVE
ESTABLISHED SUPPORT SYSTEMS BY
FAILING TO PAY PEOPLE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE WAGES, BY FAILING TO
FUND OUR CHILDREN CHILD CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE, BY FAILING TO
ESTABLISH ACCESSIBLE, QUALITY
HEALTH CARE. THESE ARE POLICY
CHOICES THAT CREATE A LANDSCAPE
IN WHICH BEING A PARENT, BEING A
MOTHER IS SO MUCH HARDER THAN IT
NEEDS TO BE. CALIFORNIA IS THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD, AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
WITH THIS BUDGET EXERCISE THAT
WE'RE ALL GOING THROUGH, WE CAN
DO BETTER AND WE MUST DO BETTER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR SKINNER
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS I RISE AS CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION,
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION VERY OFTEN
GOES UNDIAGNOSED, AND IT IS VERY
GOOD THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
PROGRAMS FOR OUR HOME NURSE
VISITATION AFTER BIRTH, NOT AS
ROBUST AS WE WOULD LIKE, BUT
STILL, BECAUSE THAT IS A TIME
WHEN IT CAN BE DETECTED. IF THE
MOTHER IS EXPERIENCING
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION.
ADDITIONALLY, WE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF BUDGET YEARS ADDED
DOULA CARE ELIGIBILITY TO OUR
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM. AND WHAT THE
DOULA CARE. ONE OF THE REAL
ADVANTAGES OF THAT, AGAIN, IS
BOTH BEING ABLE TO DETECT
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION AND TO
SUPPORT THE MOTHER AS SHE GOES
THROUGH IT, I MYSELF HAD
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION THAT WAS
NOT DIAGNOSED. I FORTUNATELY
RECOVERED FROM IT RELATIVELY,
QUICKLY BEFORE THE END OF THE
THREE MONTH PERIOD. BUT IT IS
COMMON WHEN THERE ARE DIFFICULT
BIRTHS OR LONG LABORS AND THE,
IF I HAD NOT HAD A THE FRIEND
SUPPORT GROUP THAT I HAD, IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY, WELL, I
DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO DETAILS,
BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
TRAGIC. AND SO I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR YOUR I VOTE ON SR 72. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SENATOR RUBIO,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
JUST SAY THAT WE OWE AN APOLOGY
TO ALL THE WOMEN. EXCUSE ME? WE
OWE AN APOLOGY TO ALL THE WOMEN
IN OUR HISTORY BECAUSE THIS IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE. AND I KNOW THAT
ESPECIALLY IN, LATINO
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
COMMUNITIES, THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ENCOURAGED
TO TALK ABOUT. AND SO WE
SUPPRESSED, YOU KNOW, THOSE
FEELINGS THAT THOSE MOTHERS HAVE
AND PREVENTS THEM FROM BEING
DIAGNOSED. AND AGAIN, I HOPE
THAT WE CAN ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HAVE DONE A DISSERVICE TO WOMEN
THAT CAME BEFORE US. BUT ALSO
ENCOURAGE THOSE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH IT TO
SPEAK ABOUT IT. BECAUSE THE MORE
YOU TALK ABOUT IT, THE MORE WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED AND NOT ONLY
FOR SERVICES, FUNDING, BUT ALSO
THE SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT YOU NEED
IN YOUR FAMILIES. AND I THANK
EVERYONE THAT SPOKE ON BEHALF OF
THIS AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 57. ELLEN AYE, ALL
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH.
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN NILO.
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. MUSIL. CALL NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 79. SENATOR GROVE, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL 1270 BY SENATOR
GROVE. AN ACT RELATING TO
AGRICULTURE AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION. THEREFORE,
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT SB 1270, WHICH IS
BROUGHT TO ME BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE, THE CDFA MARKET
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH PROVIDES
SEVERAL IMPORTANT SERVICES TO
FARMERS THROUGHOUT OUR STATE,
AND THEN ALSO PROVIDES SERVICES
OF OVER $40 BILLION OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES. THE BRANCH IS ALSO
100% INDUSTRY FUNDED. HOWEVER
THE FEES HAVEN'T BEEN ADJUSTED
IN ALMOST TEN YEARS. SB 1270
MODERNIZES THE FEE STRUCTURE IN
THE MARKET. ENFORCEMENT BRANCH
BY UPDATING LICENSE AND
APPLICATION FEES AND REVISING
COM COMPLAINT FEES TO BE TIERED
BASED ON THE VALUE OF THE
COMPLAINT. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES A MARKET ENFORCEMENT
ENFORCEMENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AS A PERMANENT COMMITTEE WITHIN
THE BRANCH, LIKE I SAID, IT WAS
BROUGHT TO US BY THE CDFA, THE
FARMING COMMUNITY IS IN
SUPPORTIVE OF IT BECAUSE THEY DO
KNOW IT PROTECTS ABOUT $40
BILLION WORTH OF COMMODITIES
THAT WE GROW HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 79. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. CORTEZ. DALLI. AYE.
DODD AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN.
GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
. HURTADO. GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MINH AYE. NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN AYE. UMMER.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SENATOR GROVE MOVES THE
CALL NOW. NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM
81 BY SENATOR NEWMAN. HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1449 BY
SENATOR NEWMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1449, WHICH WOULD
EXPAND AN EXISTING EXEMPTION TO
THE PRIVATE POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION ACT OF 2009 TO PROVIDE
REGULATORY RELIEF TO
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES. IN 2010, THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ISSUED
NEW RULES THAT REQUIRED
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO MAINTAIN A PROCESS FOR
RECEIVING AND PROCESSING
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS. IN 2015,
THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION INVITED
SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL TO ENTER
INTO A COMPLIANCE CONTRACT. TO
SATISFY THIS REQUIREMENT.
RECENTLY, HOWEVER, THE BUREAU
NOTIFIED SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL
THAT THOSE CONTRACTS WERE MADE
IN ERROR AND THAT ABSENT
ACCREDITATION, SOUTHWESTERN
WOULD NEED TO BECOME BUREAU
LICENSED OR FALL OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW. SB
1449 RECTIFIES THIS ERROR AND
AUTHORIZES THE BUREAU TO
CONTRACT WITH SOUTHWESTERN LAW
SCHOOL TO. PURSUANT TO FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS. I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND FILE ITEM 81. ALAN AYE, AYE.
RODRIGO Ã. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. CORTESE AYE.
DALLY. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NILO. AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN UMBERG.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SENATOR SENATOR NEWMAN
MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF PAUSE
.
SENATOR WIENER, FOR WHAT
PURPOSE? UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS, I'D LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT FILE ITEM 131 SB 1194 BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO LIFT THE CALLS ON THE
OUTSTANDING ITEMS FIRST. FIRST
UP IS FILE ITEM THREE.
ALL RIGHT. CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM THREE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. EGGMAN GROVE.
JONES MCGUIRE. AYE. UMBERG.
WIENER AYE. EYES. EYES 31. NOES
FIVE. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FOUR. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. Þ. RODRIGO. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. DODD AYE. EGGMAN
MCGUIRE. AYE. UMBERG. AYES 31.
NOES SEVEN. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM SIX. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALVARADO. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. DALLI EGGMAN.
GROVE JONES. MCGUIRE. AYE.
NGUYEN NILO. UMBERG EYES 31.
NOES TWO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 16. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. DALLI EGGMAN.
GROVE HURTADO. AYE JONES.
MCGUIRE. AYE SATO. UMBERG AYES
34. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE IS
APPROVED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 57. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CABALLERO. AYE EGGMAN.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE. JONES
MCGUIRE. AYE NGUYEN. SATO UMBERG
. AYES 35. NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE IS APPROVED NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM 79, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CABALLERO
AYE. CðC. AYE. EGGMAN MCGUIRE.
AYE UMBERG. EYES 38 NOES! ZERO!
THE MEASURE IS APPROVED. AND NOW
OUR FINAL ITEM. FILE ITEM 81.
CABALLERO AYE. EGGMAN MCGUIRE.
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYES 38.
NOES ZERO. NO! THE MEASURE IS
APPROVED NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME FOR ANY
MEMBER WISHING TO REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NO MEMBERS DESIROUS OF
SUCH SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 129. PLEASE
READ. I'M SORRY. SENATE BILL 901
963 1324 1464 1489. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ DALLI. AYE. DODD.
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OKOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
. SOURTOE AYE. SKINNER AYE.
STERN. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMMER. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CORTEZ. AYE
EGGMAN. LIMÓN. AYE RUBIO. AYE
UMMAT. AYES 38. NOES ZERO. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED.
NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. NOW IS
THE TIME FOR A COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT. SENATOR LAIRD,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL MEET IMMEDIATELY UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2100, IN THE
SWING SPACE BUDGET. SUB ONE WILL
MEET IMMEDIATELY AFTER
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2100.
SENATOR MENGIBAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND BUDGET SUB THREE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET 15 MINUTES AFTER SESSION IN
ROOM 1200. BUDGET SUB THREE WILL
MEET IN ROOM 1215 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION. SENATOR PADILLA THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. BUDGET SUB
FOUR ON STATE GOVERNMENT AND
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONVENE AT
NOON HERE IN ROOM 113 IN THE
CAPITOL. BUDGETS UP FOUR WILL
MEET AT NOON HERE IN THE CAPITOL
IN ROOM 113. SENATOR CABALLERO
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, IT'S THE DAY YOU'VE ALL
BEEN WAITING FOR THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
MEET 30 MINUTES AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT OF TODAY'S SESSION
IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING IN ROOM
2200. AND FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, PLEASE BE REMINDED
THAT WE CAN'T BEGIN OUR BUSINESS
UNTIL ALL MEMBERS ARE PRESENT.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
MEET 30 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2200, IN THE
SWING SPACE. NOW MEMBERS WERE
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS THE TIME FOR
ADJOURNMENT, ADJOURNMENT,
MEMORIES. MEMBERS, ARE YOU
PREPARED? WE ASK THAT YOU GIVE
OUR MEMBERS THEIR YOUR
ATTENTION. SENATOR ATKINS,
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY AND
WILL BE JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ENCINITAS AS WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF JOAN KLEIN JACOBS, AN
INCREDIBLE COMMUNITY LEADER AND
PHILANTHROPIST WHO DIED MAY 6TH,
2024, AT THE AGE OF 91. JOAN
KLEIN GREW UP IN NEW YORK CITY
AND ATTENDED BARNARD SCHOOL FOR
GIRLS. SHE WAS THE ONLY CHILD OF
SAMUEL AND JOSEPHINE KLEIN. SHE
EARNED A BACHELOR OF SCIENCE
FROM THE COLLEGE OF HUMAN
ECOLOGY AT CORNELL UNIVERSITY,
AND THEN WORKED AS A DIETICIAN
FOR A SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A
HOSPITAL IN UPSTATE NEW YORK. IT
WAS AT CORNELL THAT SHE MET HER
HUSBAND, IRWIN JACOBS. THEY WERE
MARRIED IN 1954, THE SAME YEAR
THAT SHE GRADUATED IN 1966. THEY
MOVED TO SAN DIEGO WHEN IRWIN
ACCEPTED A POSITION AS PROFESSOR
OF COMPUTER SCIENCE AND
ENGINEERING AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, SAN DIEGO. THEY PUT
DOWN ROOTS IN LA JOLLA IN 1968
AND NEVER LEFT. IRWIN WAS
CO-FOUNDER OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FIRM
QUALCOMM, WHICH PROVIDED THE
COUPLE WITH THE MEANS TO SUPPORT
VARIOUS CULTURE, SCIENTIFIC,
CHARITABLE AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION. THE JACOBS WERE AMONG
THE ORIGINAL SIGNERS OF THE
GIVING PLEDGE CAMPAIGN,
ORGANIZED BY WARREN BUFFETT AND
BILL AND MELINDA GATES, TO
DONATE THE MAJORITY OF THEIR
WEALTH TO CHARITABLE CAUSES.
THEY'VE DONATED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OVER THE
YEARS, INCLUDING CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE SAN DIEGO SYMPHONY, UCSD,
JACOBS SCHOOL OF ENGINEERING,
THE JACOBS MEDICAL CENTER, THE
LA JOLLA PLAYHOUSE, SALK
INSTITUTE, MUSEUM OF
CONTEMPORARY ART, SAN DIEGO, THE
SAN DIEGO CENTRAL LIBRARY, OUR
JEWISH COMMUNITY SERVICE, THE
SAN DIEGO FOOD BANK, PLANNED
PARENTHOOD, ON AND ON AND ON,
JOAN GOT PERSONALLY INVOLVED
WITH SEVERAL EDUCATIONAL AND
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS. SHE LOVED
ARTS AND CULTURE. SHE SERVED ON
THE BOARD OF THE UC SAN DIEGO
FOUNDATION, THE PLAYHOUSE, LA
JOLLA PLAYHOUSE, THE UCSD HEALTH
ADVISORY BOARD OF THE JACOBS
MEDICAL FOUNDATION, THE SYMPHONY
ENDOWMENT FOUNDATION, AND THE
MUSEUM OF CONTEMPORARY ART, SAN
DIEGO, AND OTHERS. SHE AND IRWIN
RECEIVED THE ANDREW CARNEGIE
MELLON PHILANTHROPY FROM
CARNEGIE FOUNDATION AND
PHILANTHROPY AND ARTS AWARD FROM
THE AMERICANS FOR THE ARTS. JOAN
WAS A RECIPIENT OF THE HELEN
BULL VANDERVOORT ALUMNI
ACHIEVEMENT AWARD FROM CORNELL
UNIVERSITY. SHE WAS ALSO AWARDED
AN HONORARY DOCTORATE IN FINE
ARTS FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MASSACHUSETTS. THE ONE THING I
WOULD SAY THAT'S A LONG LIST OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR SOMEONE WHO
WAS ABSOLUTELY CONSIDERED A
MATRIARCH IN SAN DIEGO
PHILANTHROPY, BUT SHE WAS
SOMEONE THAT DIDN'T LIKE TO BE
IN THE LIMELIGHT. OFTEN THEY
GAVE AND THEY DIDN'T WANT THEIR
NAME ATTACHED TO IT UNLESS IT
WOULD INSPIRE OTHER CIVIC
LEADERS WITH MEANS TO DO SO.
JOAN AND IRWIN WERE TRUE
PARTNERS IN EVERY ENDEAVOR,
INCLUDING PLANNING WHERE TO MAKE
THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS. YOU SELDOM
SAW ONE WITHOUT THE OTHER, AND I
RECALL THAT IF YOU ASK IRWIN TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOMETHING HE
ALWAYS SAID, ALWAYS, THEY HAD TO
DISCUSS IT WITH JOAN AND HE
WOULD GET BACK TO YOU, WHEN JOAN
WAS DIAGNOSED, I THINK MOST OF
US DID NOT KNOW THAT SHE WAS
DIAGNOSED, ALMOST. WELL, 50
MONTHS AGO, ACCORDING TO THE
FAMILY, WITH A SERIOUS HEART
CONDITION. AND THE DOCTORS TOLD
HER SHE HAD MAYBE SIX MONTHS TO
LIVE. SHE LIVED 50. MOST PEOPLE
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE SHE
COULDN'T, SHE COULDN'T CONCEIVE
OF LEAVING IRWIN ALONE, IT WAS A
WONDERFUL CELEBRATION OF LIFE.
THIS PAST MONDAY AT THE RADY
SHELL, WHICH IS OUR HOME ON THE
WATER IN THE BAY OF OUR
SYMPHONY. AND JOAN HAD A LOT TO
DO WITH THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
RADY SHELL. AND IF YOU GET A
CHANCE TO COME TO SAN DIEGO, I
HOPE YOU'LL TAKE IN THE SYMPHONY
OR A CONCERT THERE. IT'S
INCREDIBLE. THE RED CHAIRS THAT
ARE THERE FOR THE PUBLIC TO SIT
IN, WHICH ARE SO COMFORTABLE.
SHE HAD SHE HAD A SAY ABOUT THAT
FROM FROM THE BROADEST OF
PERSPECTIVES TO THE DETAILS, I
WOULD SAY THAT IRWIN AND JOAN
TOGETHER WERE THE ULTIMATE POWER
COUPLE FOR A GOOD CAUSE
THOUGHTFUL, INTELLIGENT TO THE
CORE REAL CLASS ACTS THROUGH AND
THROUGH THE UNION-TRIBUNE
INTERVIEWED, A LOT OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WERE THERE, THE COMMUNITY
THAT TURNED OUT TO CELEBRATE HER
LIFE ON MONDAY. AND I THINK THE
BYLINE WAS A WOMAN OF GRIT,
DETERMINATION AND GRACE AND
DEFINITELY A MATRIARCH. NOT JUST
IN THE WORDS OF HER
GRANDDAUGHTER, CONGRESSWOMAN
SARA JACOBS, NOT JUST A
MATRIARCH FOR THE FAMILY, BUT
FOR THE COMMUNITY OF SAN DIEGO.
AS I SAID, SHE SURVIVED BY HER
HUSBAND, IRWIN, THEY WERE
MARRIED 70 YEARS, 70 DOCTOR
IRWIN JACOBS, AND SHE HAD FOUR
SONS, GARY, HAL, PAUL AND JEFF
AND THEIR RESPECTIVE SPOUSES, AS
WELL AS 14 GRANDCHILDREN,
INCLUDING CONGRESSWOMAN SARA
JACOBS AND TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. MOST OF THEM
SPOKE AND SHARED THEIR STORIES
AND LOVE OF THEIR MOTHER AND
GRANDMOTHER AND GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. ON MONDAY, A
GRATEFUL SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
REALLY WAS IN ATTENDANCE AT THE
SYMPHONY'S RADY SHELL TO SHOW
THE LOVE AND GRATITUDE FOR JOAN
AND FOR THE ENTIRE FAMILY. I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY IN MEMORY
OF JOAN JACOBS. HER LEGACY WILL
LIVE ON THROUGH THE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT BENEFITED
FROM HER GENEROSITY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO THE JACOBS FAMILY AND THANK
HER FOR HER AMAZING
CONTRIBUTIONS AND WE ASK THAT
YOU BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO
SHE CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED
. AND NEXT UP IS SENATOR
MARGAVAR. OH, I'M SORRY, SENATOR
BLACKSHEAR. YES. THANK YOU. I AM
GRATEFUL TODAY TO ALSO RISE IN
MEMORY TO JOIN MY SAN DIEGO
COLLEAGUE, AND ALSO RISE IN
MEMORY OF JOAN KLEIN JACOBS, A
WOMAN WHOSE LEGACY AS A
VISIONARY LEADER, PATRON OF THE
ARTS, AND GLOBAL PHILANTHROPIST
WILL LIVE ON THROUGH THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL GIFTS OF HER
TIME, TALENT AND TREASURE THAT
BOTH SHE AND HER HUSBAND IRWIN
GAVE SO GENEROUSLY. JOAN PASSED
AWAY ON MAY 6TH, 2024, AT AGE
91, LEAVING HER HUSBAND OF 69
YEARS, FOUR SONS AND 14
GRANDCHILDREN, INCLUDING
CONGRESSWOMAN SARA JACOBS AND
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. THE OLD
SAYING IS THAT BEHIND EVERY
SUCCESSFUL MAN IS A WOMAN IN THE
CASE OF IRWIN JACOBS, JOAN WAS
THE SUCCESSFUL WOMAN BESIDE HER
HUSBAND. THEY WERE TRULY LIFE
PARTNERS WHOSE EXTRAORDINARY
LEVEL OF GIVING PLACES THEM
AMONG THE WORLD'S MOST GENEROUS
PHILANTHROPISTS. IT'S A TRIBUTE
TO THEIR SHARED VALUES THAT JOAN
AND IRWIN JACOBS CHOSE TO COMMIT
DECADES OF THEIR LIVES AND
TREMENDOUS PERSONAL RESOURCES TO
MAKING THE WORLD A BETTER PLACE.
IN 2018, THEY WERE AMONG THE
FIRST TO JOIN BILL GATES AND
WARREN BUFFETT'S GIVING PLEDGE
INITIATIVE, WHICH CALLS UPON
INDIVIDUALS OF CONSIDERABLE
MEANS TO DONATE THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR WEALTH DURING THEIR
LIFETIMES TO MEET PRESSING NEEDS
AND CHALLENGES. THE ENORMOUS
GENEROSITY OF THE JACOBS HAS
TOUCHED THOUSANDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS AS
THE PRESTIGIOUS CARNEGIE MEDAL
OF PHILANTHROPY WAS ONE OF THE
MANY ACCOLADES THAT THEY
RECEIVED, THERE, INSPIRATION WAS
DEEPLY ROOTED IN VALUES THAT
THEY LEARNED EARLY IN LIFE.
DURING THEIR MODEST CHILDHOODS,
THEY ABSORBED THE JEWISH VALUES
OF SUDOKU, WHICH MEANS A
PERSON'S RESPONSE, ABILITY TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE GOOD OF
SOCIETY, AND CARE FOR THOSE IN
NEED AND MITZVAH. THE DOING OF
GOOD DEEDS. THEY EMPHASIZE THESE
PRACTICES ALL OF THEIR LIVES. A
LITTLE OF THE JACOBS EARLY
HISTORY DEMONSTRATES THEIR
COMMITMENT TO NOT ONLY ONE
ANOTHER, BUT TO THE THINGS THEY
LOVE. THE VIVACIOUS JOAN WON THE
HEART OF THE MORE RESERVED
ENGINEERING STUDENT IRWIN, AFTER
THEY MET ON A BLIND DATE DURING
THEIR SOPHOMORE YEAR AT CORNELL.
THEY MARRIED SOON AFTER SHE
GRADUATED WITH A DEGREE FROM THE
COLLEGE. FROM THE COLLEGE, THE
COLLEGE OF HUMAN ECOLOGY. EXCUSE
ME? THEIR PHILANTHROPIC GIVING
FOLLOWED THEIR INTERESTS. JOAN
LOVED THE ARTS, CULTURE AND
HEALTH, WHILE IRWIN LOVES
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY. IN
ADDITION, THEY STRONGLY
SUPPORTED EDUCATION,
HUMANITARIAN SERVICES, PEACE AND
JUSTICE. GROWING UP IN NEW YORK
CITY, JOAN EXPERIENCED THE
WONDERS OF ARTS AND CULTURE
THROUGH THE EYES OF A CHILD.
LATER SHE BECAME A CHAMPION OF
THE ARTS. SHE HELPED TO BUILD
MUSEUMS, PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ART
COLLECTIONS, THE SAN DIEGO
SYMPHONY AND A NEW STATE OF THE
ART CONCERT VENUE, WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE REFERRED TO THE RADY
SHELL AT JACOBS PARK. SHE
PERSONALLY CHOSE PIECES OF THE
JOAN KLEIN JACOBS HEALING ARTS
COLLECTION THAT WERE INSTALLED
THROUGHOUT THE JACOBS MEDICAL
CENTER AT UC SAN DIEGO BECAUSE
SHE BELIEVED IN THE HEALING
POWER OF ART. IN ADDITION TO
FINANCIAL SUPPORT, SHE
VOLUNTEERED HER TIME AND SERVED
ON PRIVATE BOARDS AND PUBLIC
COMMISSIONS. IN 2008, SHE
RECEIVED AN HONORARY DOCTORATE
IN FINE ARTS FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF MASSACHUSETTS. SOON AFTER HER
GRADUATION, JOAN BEGAN
CONTRIBUTING TO CORNELL,
EVENTUALLY, A COMBINED GIFTS FOR
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH ROSE TO
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS JOAN AND IRWIN ENDOWED
CHAIRS AND SCHOLARSHIPS. THEY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE CONSTRUCTION
OF SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY
CENTERS, HOSPITALS, LABS, AND
RESEARCH INSTITUTES SUPPORTING
EDUCATION WAS A PRIORITY FOR
JOAN BECAUSE BOTH SHE AND IRWIN
PERSONALLY BENEFITED FROM
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT WHEN THEY
ATTENDED UNIVERSITY. IRWIN WAS
HIRED TO BUILD THE SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING AT THE NEW
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN SAN
DIEGO IN 1966. JOAN WAS A BUSY
MOTHER OF FOUR SONS, BUT WAS
ALSO ENGAGED IN THE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY. OVER THE YEARS, SHE
CHAIRED AND SERVED ON NUMEROUS
BOARDS AND COMMITTEES AT UC SAN
DIEGO. SHE EMPHASIZED THE NEED
FOR A HOLISTIC EDUCATION FOR ALL
STUDENTS SO THEY WOULD GRADUATE
AS WELL-ROUNDED, SOCIALLY
RESPONSIBLE, AND CULTURALLY
AWARE YOUNG ADULTS, NOT JUST
BRILLIANT ENGINEERS. IN 2020,
IRWIN AND JOAN WERE THE
INAUGURAL RECIPIENTS OF UC SAN
DIEGO'S LIFETIME LEGACY AWARD.
FOLLOWING HIS ACADEMIC CAREER,
IRWIN CO-FOUNDED LINKABIT AND
THEN QUALCOMM, A HUGELY
SUCCESSFUL GLOBAL TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY THAT DEVELOPED THE BASIC
COMPONENTS OF WIRELESS
COMMUNICATIONS. JOAN AND IRWIN
SUPPORT FOR GOOD GOVERNANCE,
PEACE, AND JUSTICE WILL HAVE
ENDURING GLOBAL IMPACTS. THEY
GAVE THE ACLU THE LARGEST
ENDOWMENT GIFT IN ITS HISTORY.
THEY FUNDED IN PERPETUITY, THE
JOAN AND IRWIN JACOBS CENTER FOR
SHARED SOCIETY, AN INITIATIVE AT
THE ISRAEL DEMOCRACY INSTITUTE
THAT AIMS TO STRENGTHEN SOCIAL
SOLIDARITY AND FOSTER COMMITMENT
TO DEMOCRATIC VALUES, WITH A
GOAL OF MEETING THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES ARISING FROM ISRAEL'S
DUAL IDENTITY AS A JEWISH NATION
STATE AND A LIBERAL DEMOCRACY.
THEIR GIFT TO THE UC SAN DIEGO
SCHOOL OF GLOBAL POLICY AND
STRATEGY SUPPORTS RESEARCH ON
HOW GLOBAL ECONOMICS AND
POLITICS ARE CHANGING, AND HOW
ADVANCES IN SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY IMPROVE POLICY AND
ALTER THE DISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH
AROUND THE WORLD, AND THEIR
SUPPORT OF THE TÊ INSTITUTE AT
NATIONAL TSING HUA UNIVERSITY IN
TAIWAN ENCOURAGES INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP. A REOCCURRING
THEME IN THE STORY OF JOAN
JACOBS IS THAT THE GIFTS THAT
SHE AND IRWIN GAVE WERE OFTEN
THE LARGEST IN THE HISTORY OF
THE ORGANIZATION THAT THEY
SUPPORTED. JOAN TOOK HER
PHILANTHROPIC GIVING VERY
SERIOUSLY AND FOUND IT
TREMENDOUSLY FULFILLING. SHE
HOPED THAT SHE COULD BE A ROLE
MODEL FOR OTHERS. WE CAN ALL
LEARN FROM HER ABOUT THE POWER
AND JOY OF GIVING, REGARDLESS OF
THE AMOUNT, BECAUSE EVERY GIFT
MAKES THE DIFFERENCE AND CAN
CHANGE A LIFE AND HAVE A LASTING
IMPACT. FOR HER GENEROSITY AND
COMMITMENT TO CREATING A BETTER
WORLD, WE HONOR AND THANK JOAN
KLEIN JACOBS FOR LIGHTING THE
WAY TO A BETTER FUTURE FOR US
ALL, AND I ASK THIS BODY TO
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU
AGAIN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO THE JACOBS FAMILY. SENATOR
MARGAVAR. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO LIFT UP THE LIFE AND
MEMORY OF KAREN LOMBARDO, A
DEEPLY BELOVED WIFE, MOTHER,
TEACHER AND BURBANK COMMUNITY
MEMBER. HER LIFE WAS SUDDENLY
AND TRAGICALLY TAKEN AWAY LAST
WEEK ON MAY 7TH AT THE YOUNG AGE
OF 57, WHEN SHE WAS MURDERED.
THE ENTIRE CITY OF BURBANK IS
REELING FROM THE DISTRESSING
LOSS. KAREN HAS A RARE
DISTINCTION. WE CAN ACCURATELY
STATE THAT SHE MADE A PROFOUND
AND LASTING IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN HER
COMMUNITY, NOT JUST HER
STUDENTS. DURING HER 30 YEARS AT
BRET HART ELEMENTARY, SHE
GENEROUSLY EXTENDED HER LOVE OF
TEACHING TO MULTIPLE ROLES
BEHIND BEYOND HER KINDERGARTEN
CLASSES, INCLUDING PERFORMING
ARTS, CHORUS AND INTERVENTION.
THE PARENTS APPRECIATED THE
SAFETY THEY FELT WHEN THEY LEFT
THEIR CHILDREN IN MISS KAREN'S
CARE. IN HER DEDICATION TO
FOSTERING A NURTURING LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WAS ALWAYS PRESENT.
HER COLLEAGUES ADMIRED HER
COLLABORATIVE SPIRIT IN THE
WORKPLACE, AND THEY ARE
DETERMINED TO CONTINUE THE
LEGACY OF EXCELLENCE. SHE LEFT
BEHIND. KAREN WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND THE DAILY CURRICULUM,
DEVOTING TIME AND DETAILED
ATTENTION TO STUDENTS UNIQUE
GROWTH AND DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS.
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN THE FUTURES OF
EVERY ONE OF THEIR STUDENTS, AND
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, KAREN
EXEMPLIFIED THE LIFELONG IMPACT.
COMPASSION AND POSITIVE SUPPORT
ONE CAN HAVE IN THE LIFE OF A
CHILD. AS A TEACHER THAT I KNOW
SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO
WERE TEACHERS HERE UNDERSTAND
FIRSTHAND. KAREN PUT THE
WELL-BEING OF OTHERS FIRST TO
THE VERY END. HER UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO HER STUDENTS, HER
LEADERSHIP AS AN EDUCATOR, AND
HER DEVOTION AS A WIFE AND
MOTHER CANNOT BE REPLACED. WHAT
WE CAN LOOK TOWARDS ARE THE
GENERATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
WILL GROW AND THRIVE, CARRYING
ON THE LEGACY OF KAREN'S LIFE
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS TO COME.
THIS DISASTER HAS LEFT A HUGE
VOID IN THE BURBANK COMMUNITY,
AND I AM SO HONORED TO HAVE THE
COMMUNITY COME OUT AND SHOW
THEIR APPRECIATION THROUGH
VIGILS AND VARIOUS LOCATIONS
THAT WE'RE PUTTING FLOWERS AND
SO FORTH FOR THIS WONDERFUL LIFE
THAT WE LOST. KAREN LEAVES
BEHIND HER HUSBAND, VINCE
LOMBARDO, AND THEIR TWO
CHILDREN. SENATORS, I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY TO SHOW
HER LOVED ONES AND THE STAFF AND
FAMILIES OF BRET HART ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL, THAT OUR GRATITUDE AND
ADMIRATION ARE FOREVER WITH THE
BURBANK LEADER, KAREN LOMBARDO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS AND MY
COLLEAGUE DID A WONDERFUL JOB
DESCRIBING AND DETAILING THIS
IMPECCABLE EDUCATOR AND
WONDERFUL MOM AND COMMUNITY
MEMBER, THE TRAGEDY OF HER
PASSING HAS TRULY TOUCHED THE
COMMUNITY. AS HAS BEEN SAID,
THIS IS A LIFELONG EDUCATOR WHO
GAVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITY, WHO
GAVE BACK TO GENERATIONS, WHO
GAVE BACK TO CHILDREN, INSPIRED
SO MANY PEOPLE TO DO WELL. AND
THAT'S WHY THE COMMUNITY LOVED
AND EMBRACED HER WHILE SHE WAS
ALIVE. AND THAT'S WHY THE
COMMUNITY IS DEEPLY MOURNING HER
PASSING. TO THIS DAY, THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND THIS
TRAGEDY ARE HORRIFIC, BUT THEY
ALSO UNDERSCORE HOW MUCH SHE
TRIED TO MITIGATE THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES AS A HUMAN BEING
IN THE IN THE COMMUNITY AND IN
HER FAMILY THAT CAUSED THIS
TRAGEDY. AND SO I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE IN ASKING THIS CHAMBER
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF KAREN
LOMBARDO, A WONDERFUL PERSON,
FANTASTIC EDUCATOR, AND WHOSE
LASTING LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO
RIPPLE THROUGH CALIFORNIA FOR
GENERATIONS. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
TO THE LOMBARDO FAMILY AND ASK
THAT YOU BRING THE NAME FORWARD
SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP, SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF OCTAVIO GUSTAVO
BOBIAN, WHO LAUNCHED THE UPWARD
BOUND PROGRAM AT THE CLAREMONT
COLLEGES AND WHO PASSED AWAY
MARCH 14TH AT THE AGE OF 89.
OCTAVIO WAS A LONGTIME CLAREMONT
RESIDENT, YET HE TOUCHED SO MANY
LIVES AND SO MANY STUDENTS WITH
HIS PROGRAM. THROUGH THE
PROGRAM, OCTAVIO RECRUITED
THOUSANDS OF FIRST GENERATION
LOW INCOME STUDENTS IN MY
DISTRICT FROM CHINO ALL THE WAY
TO EL MONTE AND ASSISTED THEM IN
GETTING INTO COLLEGE, HE TOLD
HIS CHILDREN THAT HE WAS ON THE
PATH OF JUVENILE DELINQUENCY,
BUT WAS ABLE TO JOIN THE
CLARETIAN SEMINARY IN DOMINGUEZ
HILL AND LATER ON, LATER ON, HE
FOLLOWED THE FOOTSTEPS OF HIS
BROTHER AND JOINED THE MILITARY,
SERVING IN THE EIGHTH ARMY
INFANTRY BATTALION PARATROOPER
UNIT BASED IN FORT BENNING,
GEORGIA DURING THE KOREAN
CONFLICT. AFTER GRADUATING FROM
CAL STATE L.A, OCTAVIO BEGAN A
CAREER OF SOCIAL WORK AND MOSTLY
FOCUSED ON BLACK AND BROWN
LATINO, YOU KNOW, CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND HELP THEM ESCAPE POVERTY AND
HELP PUT THEM IN A PATH OF
SUCCESS THROUGH THE UPWARD BOUND
PROGRAM, HE ALSO SAW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE HIS STUDENTS
A BETTER LIFE, THAT A COLLEGE
EDUCATION WAS AN ENGINE OF
SOCIAL MOBILITY AND PROSPERITY,
AND ENCOURAGED THEM TO ATTEND.
THANKS TO HIM, THE PROGRAM GREW
INTO A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
MODEL OF EXCELLENCE, DEVELOPING
THE PROGRAM SO HIS STUDENTS
WOULD BE EXPOSED TO SCIENCE,
TECHNOLOGY, POLITICS, POLICY,
AND THE WILDERNESS. ALTHOUGH
OCTAVIO SUFFERED FROM
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE, AS YOU
KNOW, IN THE LATER YEARS HE LOST
HIS FAVORITE IDENTITY, WHICH WAS
BEING A FATHER AND A HUSBAND AND
MANY WILL REMEMBER HIM, EVEN
THOUGH HE DIDN'T HAVE HIS
MEMORY. IN THE END, SO MANY WILL
REMEMBER HIM, NOT ONLY BECAUSE
OF WHAT HE DID FOR DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN, BUT BECAUSE THEY Þ HIS
SUCCESS. THEIR SUCCESS IN LATER
LIFE, AND THEIR CAREERS TO THE
UPWARD UPWARD BOUND PROGRAM. HE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE, SEVEN
CHILDREN AND 17 GRANDCHILDREN. A
COMMUNITY WILL FLOURISH BECAUSE
OF WHAT HE LEFT BEHIND AND HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS. PLEASE HELP ME
JOIN IN ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY
OF OCTAVIO GUSTAVO BOBIAN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
AND ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO IT CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE JOURNAL, IF
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR GROVE, THE DUST IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL 330, AT WHICH
TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY, MAY 20TH, AT 2:00 IN THE
AFTERNOON. HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE'LL RECONVENE ON MONDAY, MAY
20TH AT 2 P.M. THANK YOU